q anon conspiracy troll and used car
salesman alex stein sexually harassed
representative aoc on the steps of the
capitol he filmed the harassment and
posted it to his social media accounts
but now he's complaining that he's being
cancelled by the lame stream media
[Music]
just some quick background in alex stein
or as he refers to himself as primetime
99 alex stein he comes from a wealthy
part of dallas texas called highland
park where most of stein's high school
classmates found him annoying immature
and you guessed it desperate for
attention anyway i'm sure most of you by
now have seen the video of stein
sexually harassing aoc on the capitol
steps but if you haven't here it is aoc
my favorite big booty latina i love you
aoc you're my favorite
she wants to kill babies but she's still
beautiful you look very beautiful in
that dress you look very sexy look at
that booty on aoc that's my favorite big
booty
latina i love it my favorite aoc nice to
meet you look how sexy she looks in that
dress
i love it aoc
hot like a tamale well i guess if anyone
out there is casting for the role of cat
calling construction worker you know who
to call but seriously though as someone
from the hispanic community i find this
behavior incredibly offensive it's not
only racist but also sexist whatever
your political affiliation or personal
opinion of aoc is i hope we can agree
that someone calling a woman their
favorite big booty latina is both
insulting and disrespectful especially
when they're accusing said woman of
wanting to kill babies and to the white
dudes out there saying it's just a joke
don't be so sensitive well then i'm sure
you wouldn't mind women joking about
your weed
weenies right here's the thing comedians
like stein are not funny their go-to
comedy routine is to punch down and
target marginal groups for a cheap laugh
the legendary comedian george carlin
said it best i think his core audience
are young white males who are threatened
by these groups i think a lot of these
guys aren't sure their manhood because
that's a problem when you're going in
through adolescence you know am i really
am i could i be i hope i'm not one of
them and the women who assert themselves
and are competent are a threat to these
men and so are immigrants in terms of
jobs after the harassment on the capital
steps stein started going on a
right-wing media tour to defend his lewd
behavior and one of the stops was margie
taylor green's podcast which makes total
sense since green is obsessed with aoc
so aoc who who was very upset you know
you're a comedian you're doing what you
do
saying things are actually quite the
compliments i was complimenting she's
jenny from the block i mean jlo is known
for her voluptuous derriere and all i
was trying to do is say you look great i
don't know why and i'm in texas and
you're in georgia so we have southern
hospitality that's how we talk you're a
beautiful lady you are a very beautiful
lady and that and i don't mean that
anything sexual i was just saying i'm
just commenting on your beauty i don't
think that that for me is some sort of
negative thing but they live in a
society where compliments are bigotry
and based in racism
it is it's it's terrible but but in our
how we feel in our culture where we
believe in um you know two genders yeah
no no there's 17 actually now
that's what some people say i know it's
insane but no
i think women should be confident if
someone if a man gives you a compliment
a woman can say thank you that's a good
thing say thank you or you know if she's
going up the stairs and someone's
yelling stuff at her she can just wave
and go on
and not go into full outrage wait what
was that say thank you or you know if
she's going up the stairs and someone's
yelling stuff at her she can just wave
and go on
and not go into full outrage so aoc
feels uncomfortable and unsafe and
marjorie taylor green a fellow
congresswoman responds by saying that
aoc should take stein's gross behavior
as a compliment and say thank you these
two have officially set up camp in that
she was asking for it territory and i
just want to point out that i watched
the whole episode and the amount of
stupidity that they packed into 60
minutes was astounding and right on cue
stein is claiming that he's being
cancelled by aoc in the lame stream
media after his dc comedy show was
called off this whole white guy whining
about being cancelled thing is getting
pretty old so let's clear something up
there is no such thing as cancel culture
it's called being held accountable for
your actions you've got free speech
which means you can say and do whatever
you want but others can choose to deal
with you however they want oh and by the
way stein relocated his dc comedy show
to the steps of the capital and this was
the turnout so yeah i'm sure the venue
was really regretting not hosting his
set especially when it consists of
spreading disinformation about michael
jordan the basketball player owning
private prisons look it up one of the
biggest guys that owns private prisons
michael jordan has one of the biggest
investors in private prison so that's no
joke and if it wasn't clear michael
jordan a basketball player does not own
any stake in private prisons this guy
does also i don't know if that was
supposed to be some sort of weird
unofficial ted talk or an anti-humor bit
but according to stein this was him
keeping it real in the hood the main
reason that stein has become well known
is thanks to texas house bill 2840 which
requires governmental bodies to give
time to public speakers and as a result
stein has exploited this rule to spread
misinformation conspiracy theories and
transphobia and because of those stunts
his videos have gone viral and he has
been welcomed on right-wing shows like
alex jones and tucker carlson which
helped build his platform as a troll in
june stein took his trolling to a gop
convention in texas where he went after
dan crenshaw calling him eyepatch mccain
and then at that same event went after
ted cruz i know but why do you do that
you go become best friends with trump
after he makes fun of you and your wife
why do you do that i i understand you
don't want to because you're
well if there's one thing i got from
this encounter it's that no one likes
ted cruz not even the people that have
been radicalized within the republican
party now what you might not know is
that alex stein was also a former
contestant on different reality tv shows
dope not that anyone would even notice
since each of his appearances were very
short-lived in 2012 stein was a
contestant on the reality tv show the
glass house
and boy was it something the end of the
day i'm a good guy with good morals
would you look at that a bad guy
thinking that they are the good guy
sounds like a republican to me and it
should come as no surprise that stein
also sexually harassed a female
contestant while he was on the show
right behind you andrea your husband
would be so this is probably the most
naked man you've seen in a long time
wildly inappropriate kevin is a little
baby bag [ __ ] i mean it's 2012. people
need to loosen up a little bit his
excuse is that it's 2012. alex alex alex
later on in the first episode stein
asked the audience if he should become a
villain should i turn into the most epic
villain in the history of reality tv
it's fantastic
however stein was so bad at playing a
villain that he served no purpose he
just annoyed everyone and by the end of
the first episode almost every
contestant voted him off the show now at
this point stein and another contestant
have been sent to the elimination round
however that other contestant decided to
quit so now it's just stein let's see
how the audience voted
imagine being overwhelmingly voted off
by the other contestants your opponent
in the elimination round quits and the
audience still doesn't want you to be on
the show and don't forget this is the
very same audience who told stein that
he should become a villain but here's
the thing there's a big difference
between playing a villain on a tv show
and being an [ __ ] no one wants to
watch an [ __ ] i'm sure if alexstein
was asked he would defend all of his
past and present behavior as him just
playing a character but if you watch him
over the years you realize that his
primetime 99 alex stein character is
really just alex stein a sexist and
racist [ __ ] well i'm gabe sanchez and
this has been what was that
[Music]
you